bonjour aujourd'hui je suis venu avec
des livres qui font grandir ses livres
qu'on aime raconter aux enfants pour les
aider à comprendre leurs sentiments
leurs émotions
le premier que je vous ai apporté c'est
celui ci s'appelle dans mon corps et
c'est un livre de mire jama fracasse
paru aux éditions la joie de lire vous
le voyez sa couverture jaune soleil
annonce déjà la couleur c'est un livre
pétillant et poétique qui raconterait
bien ce qui se passe à l'intérieur du
corps toutes les émotions qu'on peut
ressentir à chaque moment de la vie
par exemple lorsqu'on boit et bien c'est
comme si des oasis poussé à l'intérieur
de notre corps et la colère c'est un peu
de sauvagerie à l'intérieur de soi quand
la joie c'est un feu d'artifice le
graphisme est magnifique et tous les
thèmes sont abordés
cela vous permettra de discuter avec vos
enfants de sentiments de ressenti à
partir de 3 ans pour les plus grands
j'ai une autre collection celle ci les
petites histoires de ça mais watson des
histoires pour la vie de ghislaine
dullier bérengère de la porte
alors c'est toujours difficile de savoir
ce qu'est le courage la colère la paix
intérieure des idées presque
philosophique mais avec sam et watson ça
devient simple comme bonjour
car watson est un chat adorable un chat
qui est toujours là pour faire un câlin
toujours là aussi pour encourager les
enfants quand ça ne va pas cette
collection est vraiment très très bien
écrite
les dessins de la franc comtoise
bérengère de la porte sont magnifiques
avec un crayonné en apparence très
simple qui parle vraiment aux enfants
c'est utile à partir de 5 ans les
grandir puisque c'est le thème de cette
chronique c'est aussi grandir en taille
et fabiola n'y arrive pas fabiola la
toute petite girafe c'est un livre de
chantal penny nom et daniel et non à la
maison d'édition anne
athée et cette toute petite girafe et
bien elle est très très embêté de ne pas
réussir à grandir de rester minuscule
alors que sa petite amie elle grandit et
elle va tout essayer pour grandir
jusqu'à finalement abandonnée et se
rendre compte qu'il faut s'accepter tel
qu'on est
alors c'est un très joli livre vous le
voyez l'illustrateur dijonnais daniel et
non un très joli coup de crayon un petit
peu désuet qui plaira aux enfants à
partir de 6 ans et puisque je vous ai
parlé point ce temps que de livres pour
les petits
j'ai décidé quand même de vous amener
celui ci qui s'appelle cavale et qui est
un livre de stéphane servant et rebecca
dautremer paru chez didier jeunesse
cavale et bien c'est ce personnage est
pourquoi s'appelle-t-il cavale et bien
parce qu'il passe son temps à courir
il court sans arrêter ils fuient fin la
fin qui pense-t-il va le rattraper il
fuit sans cesse jusqu'à ce qu'ils se
heurtent à montagne montagne qui elle ne
bouge pas et qui est une force
tranquille
leur rencontre va donner lieu un
changement total de points de vue et de
vie pour cavale alors c'est un vrai
conte philosophique car ce n'est pas
directement accessible je pense qu'il
faut attendre au moins huit ans et puis
peut-être une médiation des parents mais
je vous le conseille pour parler de la
vie de la mort de l'amour et pour
peut-être ralentir et prendre le temps
de lire